- HI, I'm Priscilla Chan.
- And I'm Sal Khan, and
we're here to announce
the Breakthrough Junior Challenge.
For those of you who don't know,
the Breakthrough Prize,
is a prize to the world's
top mathematicians and scientists
for discoveries that are going to
change the world around us.
And the Breakthrough Junior Challenge
is to reach out to high school students,
with the recognition that
the biggest breakthroughs
start with an insight, with a
new way of looking at things.
It could be existing
discoveries or theories,
it could be a recent one,
or it could be something that
you discover on your own.
- We want to hear from you.
All you scientists, tinkers,
innovators in the world,
send us your video.
We want to hear from you by October 7th,
in a short video where you explain
what you're excited about these days.
- And what do they win?
- This is pretty exciting in itself.
You'll win a college scholarship,
your teacher will get a prize for being
such an important mentor in your life,
and your school gets a
brand new lab for everyone
to be able to work hands-on
and learn about science.
- [Sal] And they get to fly out here.
- Oh yea, this is the most glamorous
science event in the world.
Best science fair ever.
- And we can't wait to
see what you produce.
We suspect that you're
going to blow our minds,
and open many, many more people's minds
to the magic of science
that will eventually lead
to future breakthroughs.
- [Priscilla] We're so excited.
We can't wait to hear from you.
(soft rock music)